does the iPhone 15 Pro Max really take
that much better photos than the iPhone
15 Pro and regular 15s well I went out
and I took a bunch of different photos
with portrait mode regular testing
detail night mode and even video to give
you guys the most in-depth comparison to
see how these compare especially now
that the iPhone 15 and 15 plus have that
48 megapixel camera starting off with
colors and dynamic range these shots
look so similar but I think the regular
iPhones have a a little bit more
saturation now looking at this beautiful
sunset photo right here looks similar
but if we punch in we see that the
sunset actually looks a l better on the
fence on the regular iPhone but I have
to say this is the closest I've ever
seen a regular iPhone to a pro phone in
terms of damc crange and colors now the
only time I saw a difference in denc
range is with portrait mode you guys can
see the sky right over there is blown
out on the regular iPhone that's
probably because of the a 16 and next
let's compare detail because both of
these shoot 48 megapixel so in this shot
right here the only thing I could tell
is that the regular iPhone is slightly
more cropped in because it has a
different lens and if we pop in here to
look closer at the detail the regular
iPhone 15 looks actually better and now
that both of them have a 2X crop here is
an example both look great and taking a
closer look I do see a little bit more
detail on the iPhone 15
plus and that is because this is
actually a brand new sensor even though
it is smaller than the one-year sensor
which came from the 14 pro and we'll see
how that does in low light now looking
at 3x this is where I added the regular
15 Pro because it has a 3X camera and if
we take a closer look we'll see that yes
the quality is definitely the best on
the 15 Pro because the other two are
cropping in from their main cameras and
taking a look at 5x cuz that is where
the pro Max switches we can see that it
is better than the other ones but not
that much better than the 3x at least
for this kind of Zoom so I think if you
zoom in for this kind of detail
especially with text the sharpening is
good but where we see the biggest
difference is from the regular iPhone 15
or the 15 plus to the pro Max which can
now zoom in 25 times compared to 10 now
what blows my mind is that even though
we're zoomed in so much more more the
actual quality is better as well and
looking at this sign right here that's
the difference in zoom and then if I
punch up the 15 plus you can't even read
that text where you can on the pro Max
bringing the 15 back into the picture
here is just a 1x shot just to show you
how far you can zoom in all the way
across the lake there and you can see
how good the pro Max is if you need to
zoom in quite a bit now of course you
can always digital crop but this is the
difference you get here 15 Pro Max
against the plus uh the plus is not
usable and then here's a real world
example where I really needed to zoom
the 15 plus looks really bad cuz it's
all digital compared to the other two
with of course the pro Max and that new
5x lens looking really good and I think
you're going to be really impressed in
the portrait section now this year Apple
added a new 24 28 and 35 mm mode where
you can switch cameras and they said you
have a ton of cameras now so I wanted to
test it in this shot it looks so similar
this is actually set at 35 mm on the pro
Max and the iPhones the regular ones
they don't have that option so let's
take a look and see if we have any more
detail and to me it is so hard to tell
the difference so in reality does it
help you using those modes as far as
quality it doesn't really seem like it
might just be more convenient not to
have to zoom in or crop later and now
let's talk about macro mode both the pro
and pro Max have the same cameras in
fact all the cameras are the same other
than the zooms whereas the pluses don't
have that but impressively the 15 Plus's
image looks great and then if I just
crop in slightly it looks amazing and
that is because the lenses are different
now if you have a subject that is way
smaller like this tiny flower that is
the closest I could get on the 15 plus
whereas a PR Max you can get those nice
macro shots and getting even closer even
smaller subject there's the pro Max's
macro mode whereas the plus I had to
digitally crop a bunch and as you guys
could see my hand is in the background
when I didn't put it there the regular
iPhones they just can't focus that well
even to take the image now it's really
cool to have that macro mode but if
you're not taking pictures of subjects
that are super small you guys could see
that here the 15 Plus's image looks
great and we have a lot more natural
background blur compared to a crop from
the ultra wide and then you could just
crop in digital a little bit and that
image looks really nice and now let's
talk about minimal focusing distance you
guys see here the 15 Pro Max is out of
focus whereas the 15 plus is in focus
and that is because even though both of
these are 48 megapixel the sensor is
larger on the pro Max and it's an older
design than this one so if you got to
take a picture of something that's close
up you can actually get it in Focus
compared to the pro Max which is out of
focus and I can actually get this close
on the 50 or 15 plus where the pro Max
can not and that just means that in
certain situations you will get a better
photo on the regular iPhone and now
switching to the ultra wide all of these
have 12 megapixel Ultra wides but they
have quite a difference now in this good
lighting shot it is hard to tell we have
a little bit of a difference in color
same thing in this shop both images look
beautiful and like I said this is the
closest I've seen them in years but if
we punch in we do see a little bit more
detail the 15 plus has more artificial
sharpening uh but in certain cases
especially when the lighting starts to
get a little dimmer like this shot in
the center you're going to see more
detail on the 15 Pro Max and in the
corners is where you will especially see
a difference in terms of sharpness and
detail so if you really like Ultra wide
shots keep that in mind and you get the
macro mode now this right here is a
panorama not a lot of people test it out
but I wanted to see here are both of
them aligned in and I will say they look
quite similar and then looking closer I
mean this is really a wash here where in
past years um the regular iPhones would
be much worse and now let's take a look
at some selfies and all of these iPhones
actually have the same exact selfie
camera so here they look so similar
apart from a slight white balance
difference now here I have a portrait
shot and both of them look so good as
well last year the iPhone 14 was quite a
bit worth wor in the portrait mode alone
because of processing but now we have
the a16 and when the lighting gets
darker I think I look a little better on
the 15 Pro Max but my wife looks better
on the 15 plus now Apple also added the
ability to make a regular photo into
Porche so want to test it out because
the regular iPhones don't have lar on
the back maybe they'd be worse because
of processing and here enabling that I
mean they look very very similar and the
same thing with this trash goat that we
have it's a tough one and enabling it
they also look so dang similar now one
thing that's often forgotten in camera
comparisons is the fact that the regular
iPhones don't have Pro raw where you get
that with the pro iPhones and let's take
a look here you see that the 15 Pro Max
is a little bit more gray and then when
I go ahead and I edit it and we punch in
it looks like the 15 plus still has more
detail even though I added sharpening on
the pro Max it's just more processing
happening right when you take the photo
now in this shot right here you see it's
extremely dark and then I went in and I
edited them and this is what we got I
mean I was surprised the plus was able
to be edited so much but if we look down
at their walkway there you have all
these mixes of colors just streams that
are not there at all and the pro Max
looks like it's a photo that was just
taken normally here is a shot outside
exposing for the sky everything is so
dark and then editing them you see that
with the pro Max I can make that look
like a good photo whereas the plus
everything falls apart and the image you
can't bring it up as much it just
doesn't look good and then the shot of
my face it's not too dark but I can
bring it up and on the plus doing so
well it starts to mess up with the
clouds dynamic range there and my face
starts looking just really weird and
extra saturation so if you like to go in
and edit your photos having Pro rot is
definitely a huge benefit and now let's
take a look at video quality so this is
regular 4K video and the 15 plus is a
little bit more zoomed in just because
of the lens and then in this 2x mode
definitely more detail from the 15 plus
and it might just be because of that new
sensor and lens but now that I switched
to 5x you guys could see all the
artifacting in the digital crop on the
regular iPhone whereas the 15 Pro Max
looks incredible I don't remember the
last we had such good video quality with
a zoom lens I know Samsung and pixels
have had Zoom but their video quality is
not this good and here looking at it
having an actual lens we actually have
VCA and blur whereas the regular iPhone
you saw everything there I also tested
out cinematic mode just to see if
lighter helps out with better cutouts
and looking at this they both look very
very close just slight imperfections on
the edges but this is a very tough shot
so don't think that you need a pro phone
for this now what about stabilization
this is using the action mode on both of
them and they both look very equally
stable and I was running like crazy in
this shot the only thing that I could
tell is that the video quality from the
ultra white on the pro phone is
definitely better and here I have some
selfie video both of them look so so
close I wouldn't say there's any
difference I think the a16 has plenty of
power now to keep up and keep the
quality perfect and then in low light
how was that smaller 48 megapixel sensor
well it looks really really good I mean
it's better in some ways maybe slightly
less detail in the text but better in
other areas so overall I'm really
impressed and the sensor in here they're
probably going to use for many years
because it is really good and now let's
get into portrait shots where it's going
to get kind of crazy we have three
different cameras we have 5x 3x and then
just a 1X with the crop now you guys see
in this shot right here uh my wife looks
really different and the background
looks really different as well and here
I'm going to start out with just the pro
Max and the plus because the regular pro
has the same exact photos in the
standard lens and the quality looks very
similar maybe actually slightly more
detail on the 15 plus same thing with my
son right here on his bike both do a
great job in punching in and seeing um
him after after he just had some
cupcakes there he looks slightly more
detailed on the 15 plus now in this shot
right here I want to see how far back
could I get and have portrait mode still
work and it's the same on both this is
right when they cut out but with the 15
plus you can get quite a bit closer to
your subject and still use portrait mode
which is really cool now the shot right
here I'm testing for uh not background
blur but foreground so you guys could
see that edge right there and the one on
the 15 Pro Max looks really good in
natural the 15 Pro actually looks the
worst now here's a regular portrait shot
for reference and then I'm going to
switch to their portrait Zoom mode so we
have 5x on the 15 Pro Max 2x maximum on
the 15 plus and 3X on the 15 Pro so
that's nice to be able to get that close
here's another example of my wife and I
mean having that 15 Pro Max shot looks
so good instead of seeing that whole
tree and everything everything kind of
just has extra separation compression it
looks awesome now that's also great for
a shot like this where the 15 plus with
its only 2x portrait you cannot actually
focus at that point you don't get a
portrait mode where the 15 Pro you do
and the pro Max you absolutely do now
framing all the images the same you guys
see a massive difference now in this
lighting the quality looks very similar
but the 15 plus at 2x mode you see so
much of that background compared to the
15 Pro gets better where you you can
still see the road but the pro Max
everything disappears and we have that
beautiful compression same thing here we
have 2X versus 5x you don't see any of
that background you just get a beautiful
portrait and it's more resistant to
flaring and then in this shot this is
just an excellent example we have a 2X
portrait a 3X and then the 5x on the 5x
I can literally kind of move away the
houses and the road there and you just
see right what's behind it so that's
called compression that's amazing to be
able to get and get just a nice looking
image now here's the first shot once
again you guys can see that beautiful
blur on the 5x lens without any
distraction in the background now on the
15 plus and on the other phones you can
actually go ahead and you can turn up
the blur to the maximum which I did here
but that still doesn't change the
compression and it doesn't change other
stuff that is in the background now one
reason why photographers love longer
lenses that are zoomed in more more for
portraits is because it makes your face
look more natural so here in the 15 plus
you guys could see there's some warping
going on even in the 2x mode whereas the
15 Pro looks better and the pro Max
looks the best the face just has a nice
proportion to it now I'm really glad
that Apple added the 2x portrait mode to
this camera because for years you just
had 1X and then because of that you
would get a shot like this where you see
that warping and then if you get closer
here's an extreme example where you have
all the warping there on the 14 but the
15 or 2x it looks better but of course
having a 3X or a 5x lens definitely
looks nice and one thing I haven't
talked about much here is the quality of
the porches as far as detail well
looking at it I'm so shocked the 5x even
though it's his longer lens usually the
quality is worse Apple's done an
incredible job with their new design
that's different from Samsung or from
Google and now we have some lower
lighting here not night modee just yet
uh but this is where it gets a little
tougher for these cameras and even
though I like the pro Max's photo the 2x
on the 15 plus looks slightly better in
quality but of course the other two pro
phones can do the same thing if you
choose now here's a shot of 5x versus 2x
now one thing that people say is that
you could just crop it and post and get
some more compression and yes that does
help out but then the quality starts to
fall apart so I wouldn't recommend doing
that and here framing them all the same
you guys just see that difference in
compression and background blur and now
let's get into night mode where it's
going to get interesting now we're going
to start out with portrait since we were
on it and here the 15 plus looks better
under this street lighting and then
looking at 2x modes on both once again
the 15 plus is looks better it's just a
newer sensor even though it's smaller
and the lens is an
f1.5 now in this shot of me we have a 5X
photo a 2X and a 3X and I will say the
5x looks really really good maybe too
warm as far as detail and the 3x on the
15 Pro doesn't really help it much
compared to the digital crop now as the
images get darker we start running into
another issue even though we have a 48
megapixel camera apple is still not
allowing this phone the 15 and 15 plus
to take night mode portraits in
combination so when you're taking a shot
like this you'll see that the 15 Pro
Maxes just looks better cuz it could do
both at the same time and in this shot
it's an even more drastic difference the
quality goes down a lot because if
you're selecting portrait you don't get
the night mode and in this picture the
portrait mode didn't even work but night
mode also didn't turn on so that really
sucks now here's another example for you
guys um in this studio of vad the
quality difference is crazy being able
to have night mode portraits and here
not as dark but we have some bokeh in
the back background I really wish Apple
would give this to us because other
Android phones have it even without lar
and now for regular night mode shots
this is an ultrawide and the difference
is insane now it was super dark here but
the 15 Plus's Ultra wide camera is just
not as good nowhere near as good if you
take a look at this image right here it
was crazy dark but this seems like
comparing you know an iPhone 10 to an
iPhone 15 in terms of quality now here
we comparing the 1X lenses both are very
very close and from this shot right here
the 15 Pro Max just looks a little bit
brighter which is what I tended to see
but one interesting thing is if you look
here the 15 Plus's image looks more
detailed than the Rocks now the water
doesn't have as much motion blur and
that's because the 15 plus tended to
take night mode pictures quicker than
the more expensive 15 Pro Max or 15 Pro
maybe because of the newer sensor this
shot right here is on a tripod and they
are both very similar other than the
plus being slightly darker and now we
are switching to a 2X crop on a
telephoto I would say the 15 Pro Max
looks a little bit brighter once again I
also wanted to add in Pro raw in night
mode so here lean is completely dark and
I push both these images as much as I
could to get some detail from her face
and the 15 pluses just falls apart
without Pro raw and now let's compare
the zoom photos in night mode this is
all of them set to 5x you can see the 15
Pro Max definitely looks the best this
is a 3X shot right here and the 15 Pro
looks better because actually has a 3X
lens instead of cropping this is another
3x shot but here the difference isn't
that big and this one is a 5x Zoom so
surprisingly the 15 Pro really kind of
kept up in night mode and then finally a
5x on all and it's crazy how much detail
we get from the 15 Pro Max and that the
15 plus even though it's a crop actually
looks better than the 15 Pro 3x lens so
overall what is my conclusion is it
worth getting the 15 Pro Max well if you
like to take portraits I would say
absolutely I love that 5x lens if you
zoom in and you take photos like that it
is great now with that said the quality
difference for regular photos with the
main camera between these have never
ever been closer many times this is
actually better so if you don't need to
zoom and you don't want to take Zoom
portraits you don't care about that and
you don't take nighttime Ultra ide
pictures I don't think you're missing
out by getting a 15 or a 15 plus it does
an awesome job but if you care about
photography there are definitely a lot
of differences you guys let me know what
shocked you the most this has been Max
and I'll see you in the next
[Music]
one